Last week, I asked you..
Leave your entries in the sub reddit bros
And I'll watch submissions in the next episode of LWIAY ( ͡°( ͡° ͜ʖ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)ʖ ͡°) ͡°)
ITS ANOTHER WEEK! It's another
LE WHY? (wtf)
Such a great name. Just rolls off the tongue. "LEEEE WHY?"
THAT'S IT!
The best show on internet. Last week, it was so popular, we got on trending...
*totally not lying. totally.*
(uhmmm.)
...
Let's see what memes you posted last week; LWIAY.
You know I usually challenge you guys. "Hey do this..." "Hey wouldn't it be cool if we...?"
W- We- we do a theme this week-- BUT NO.
It's ALWAYS JUST memes.
J̸̜̮͈͇͇̾͋̊̈́̓̇̔͋ṵ̸̡͚̪͉̜͇̪̹̟̖̯̤͉͛͐̿̋͊̋̃̓̒͐͠s̸̡̡̤͕͍̱͓̘̒̏̀͋͛̀̂̽̈̈͝ţ̷̘̺͇͖̝͇̣̟̗͕̬̭̔̓͗̊͛̋͑͋̎̈́͊ ̵͙̙̪̟̰͇̩͖̟̱̽̒͘M̴̩̥̝̿̍̉̈́̆̒͊̌̄͗͐̔͛̏o̷̡͚͚̥̱̳̣̲̠͂̐͋͋̊̈́̂̉́̿̈́̕n̴̢̢͕̤̰̦̣̼̻͎̥̙͓̰̿͊͘̕i̸̤͓̝̭͍͍͍̲̤̗̖̩̫͓̭̒͗̓̃̑̕̚͠͝k̵̨̭̪͍̖̮͓̀̄̕ͅ- memes.
JUST memes.
*disappointment*
And I'm always the end of the joke. It's like a collective of people throwing shit at me, and I have to deflect
*Extremely Realistic Deflecting Noises*
Left and right *Pow Pow Pow* I ha-
Yes, I have original ideas there are some good videos
*More Pows*
*dab*
NO MY CHANNEL ISN'T WASHED UP, IT STILL GETS MILLIONS OF VIEWS
*POWPOWPOWPOWPOWPOW*
Yeah- oh- oh, so, so you ca- you can't afford paying $300 for a chair, and I've completely lost touch with reality --
Tha- that's not
Typically the amount that you would pay, but can you dOOO THIIIIS!
*goodbye guys*
*HIYA*
Great -- oh, look at that. It's a repost of me reposting a repost.
Congratulations. If Felix says 'stop reposting my tweets,' then why he reposts our memes?
*Illuminati Music Plays*
Shut the fu-
Can't be the most hated person on the Internet if there is no Internet
*Laughs*
YouTube rewind was shit. Guess who did not get featured on YouTube rewi-
Oh for f-
*crying on the inside*
It's not funny...
Okay...?
"Skrattar du förlorar du" (You laugh, you lose)
"What?"
"It means you are the love of my life in Swedish"
"Aww, babe-" *laughs*
That's right -- y'all just throw shit at my direction.
I'm helping you get laid.
With such l- wonderful, new language, that I'm teaching you,
I am inviting you to the world of Swisstian.
Skrattar du förlorar du.
It will make any pussy drip like Niagara Falls
Christian channel.
Remember boo?
This is her now. Feel old yet?
NO
You know, tha- that looks like that shitty new trailer that everyone's posting about.
Hey, that's her now.
*stumbling with words*
Clearly that's the meme, loo- *stumbling with words again*
Do I have to make the memes *for you* now?!
Is that what this has come to?!
Learn how to f-
*Christian channel*
Learn how to bleepin' meme! If you're gonna post on my reddit!
Do you think this is some sort of joke?!
"No Title Needed."
Buddy, If you're good at something, Never do it for free.
"Stolen memes" I think I make five bucks from these.
*get the fuck out of here...*
"Haters," "YouTube demonesation... demone-tization," "Media," "Pewdiepie," "Reddit." Ah...
Can you add another frame to this where Reddit puts a dagger in my back?
How 'bout that? Then it's accurate. Then I will give it a little *laugh*
Pewds in high school.
ry = ln (cᵉ) + ln (ni/v)
ry = ln ((cᵉ)...
C raised E. (C raised to E). I don't know the.. English
Terminology... you're al- you're always so up in my ass about things, like I said the A 2 B 2 squared and *complaint noises*
In Sweden, we say A 2, *ehh*
i kvadrat (squared)
*swedish* Means *ehhh*
Squared. So it's- jus- just shut up... is what I'm trying to tell you. And that becomes E R Y
When you remove the ln...
Which becomes C E N I B, which becomes
ver-
*laughing*
V times E raised to RY
Okay, very it becomes very nice
Now this is math
This is why I dropped out of high school
Which I didn't, out of university, I dropped out of university ok
I'm not some sort of pleb that didn't make it through high school who drops out at the high school
When I say very n- *stutters* very nice, it's not just me
Having the lack of better word and repeating myself constantly because I'm not smart enough
It's me challenging you guys with
complex mathematical equations to see are you paying attention, is he saying very nice or
VERY nice. It's a it's a black and white difference, and you can't argue against it
I'm putting way too much emphasis into one single image, and we have a lot to go through so let's keep going.
Tables have turned (very nice dead meme)
*laughs*
*inhales*
Ok that was like I was a good good example of a
*stutters*
Reverse petting dog meme, well done.
I created a reddit account just to submit this.
ok, well it has to be good.
I will be aborted
soon-*laughs in the middle of word*
I'm not even gonna finish it
*laughs again*
Rewind 2017
Raise that finger doggy.
There you go. (very nice)
That's, that's how you do the image
Inspiring quotes by famous people. "A man is but the product of his thought
Thoughts of what he thinks he becomes".
"Education is the most powerful weapon which you can use to change the world."
*while laughing* "Buy my chair, it's only $399".
Yes, yes it is only $399 and I'll have you let you know, but can you do this?
(nope)
I Don't think so.
Am I doing this right?
That's a pretty good Photoshop. I got it
Well done good job.
Oh, it's a Doki Doki meme. (ok)
Watching pewds play Doki Doki.
*laughs*
Pretty accurate I must say.
Got what you wanted. Hey look at that?
Told you. I told you I could have held their hands
Good meme, good meme. Well done. Well done. I see no difference.
oh my god
Actually, yeah, what the heck? One doesn't have a pedo beard.. goddamit. Can I?
The real reason Why pewdiepie wasn't in YouTube rewind, it's because the video wasn't ten minutes.
Yeah, Why did they not make it ten minutes?
but they know that they can just make the outro three minutes longer, and then they get three times the revenue
Imagine if you had me work, and you have to do a specific amount of work,
But you could get three times more for that work, if you happen to make the video ten minutes long
*laughs*
When pewds has died like five thousand times?
but it's still zero deaths. Told you guys. I challenge you intellectually and I'm glad that you're thinking.
When it's January and your shirt forshadows the future...
*exhales from nose harshly*
I Remember wearing that in January.
I Foreshadowed the future. Okay.
I wore that thinking; yes. This is actually true I even said it in videos
2017 is the year where it's all gonna go down for me, because I knew the media where the media was going with it
Okay, I'm not stupid low-effort memes guys literally only want one thing
And it's effing disgusting original content
*claps sarcastically*
Good job
*laughs*
*claps again*
What happened?
Listen, this hair, this hair...
I Fuckin rock it okay. You wish, you wish that you can have this hair.
Get into trending, come on.
I haven't seen a single one of my videos get to trending in 84 years
2017 - 84
is 1933. (wtf)
Federal election were held in Germany in 1933
Adolf Hitler height,
PewDiePie height,
Coincidence? I think not.
*what the fuck am i doing with my life*
S T A H P
First "very nice" on the Christian Channel, very nice.
oh shit, you're right.
*flashbacks*
♩I will remember you
(I will remeber you - Sarah Mclachlan) I will remember you,
Will you remember me?
Don't let your love♩
Weep not for the memories.
Ummm,
Okay, okay, everybody that was this week's of LWIAY rolls right off the tongue
Okay, okay, everybody that was this week's of LWIAY. Rolls right off the tongue
Beautiful, well done. You know what for for once? I will only say this once ever, good job.
You did a good job, very nice. This week was very nice, Well Done
Remember to leave a like and watch this video multiple times, so we can get it on trending.
Share it.
subscribe.
but also squad fam
squadfa-
(bOOOOOOM)